J'avais six ans, ma baby-sitter a été assassinée et
ils ne l'ont jamais attrapé. Justice a été rendue.
Je veux jouer à Vica. Les meurtres étaient du vrai
foie de Sookie.
ill Chucky m'a dit
qu'il venait pour toi,
il est important que nous l'explorions tous
ensemble en tant que groupe Je pense que j'ai
quelque chose qui aidera whoa d'accord
Je suis Chucky veux jouer
[Music] d'
abord Je vais tuer chacun d'entre
vous  les façons les plus horribles que vous puissiez
imaginer et ensuite il me tuera aussi
avez-vous peur de la vérité terrifié vous
devriez être trop nuit-nuit et ils
m'appellent malade attendez une minute il y en a deux
un 2000 se démode jamais